hey everybody welcome back to Planet Zoo
and today I'll be doing something
slightly different from what I usually
do are we making a pack of blueprints
and there will be five blueprints and
five matching time lapses in this video
in total you can download them in the
description I'll leave a workshop link
there and also that's basically and
actually there's not much else to
introduce now for everybody who is
wondering why I'm still not making a zoo
or why I'm still just building buildings
in general well for one I was really
afraid to start recording an actual
franchise mode playthrough right from
the get-go because I noticed that
everybody kept going bankrupt and so did
I honestly and thankfully yesterday the
lady signer uploaded a tutorial showing
how she managed to make a profit in
franchise mode so for now my plan is to
try and make a profit in franchise mode
not record it because I don't want to
get known for my failures honestly but
as soon as I get something going that
actually works I would like to keep
building from there and see what kind of
sue I can make in the remaining time
that we have the beta now also you know
at the end of the day I want to build
these buildings as a way to practice the
scenery pieces everything in the game is
new to me and even though I might be
used to the building system I have no
idea how the pieces work together how to
actually make buildings out of the
themes so I'm basically building these
buildings as much as possible to try and
come to grips with the scenery options
that we have + and I know this is
probably a bit sassy but you know this
is coming from me and I'm the person
who's been making a ski resort and
planet coaster as well as modern
apartments and Japanese gardens and all
kinds of non theme park related
activities and honestly I see these
games more as a general creative tool
than something where you have to build
exactly what the game intends to do so
yeah I just like experimenting in these
things and kind of stepping outside the
boundaries of just what they're meant
for plus that's kind of what I do so
especially in the beginning I wanted to
focus on doing scenery as opposed to
starting a franchise mode
which basically everyone on YouTube is
doing and I think if you want to see a
franchise mode playthrough focus on
gameplay and economics there are lots of
amazing channels out there I just think
that I'm not really the person who is
best suited to do that sort of stuff
alright so now that that whole long
intro is out of the way let's actually
talk about what I'm doing in this
episode so I'm going to be building a
bunch of Indian blueprints and the
specific style that I was most inspired
by is in nursery scenic architecture
which is actually a style of
architecture that I have a folder on a
folder of on my computer with a bunch of
reference images and inspiration and
information just because I've always
wanted to make a themed area in a theme
park and planet coaster in this style I
was originally intending to include it
in fantasy valley but that never really
developed into anything it's just a
style that I've always found really
interesting and really beautiful
although I have to say and this is going
to be my short introduction of what this
now actually means it's a little bit
controversial at least political in a
sense that a lot of architectural styles
are political because it's not entirely
Indian I would say I mean at the end of
the day Indian architecture is very
diverse there are different
architectural styles throughout India
there have been different ones
throughout history and a lot of the
architecture in India is a sort of
eclectic mix of different styles of
architecture but this one specifically
was created by British Architects in the
late 19th century kind of as a response
to the uprising in India and 1857 when
Britain decided to very much change the
way that it ruled the country and I'm
not going to make any political comments
because opening their whole colonization
history is just a Pandora's box that I'm
not going to open in a blended sous-vide
of all things but they try to become
more inclusive and try to adapt to the
styles of India itself and the kind of
the mix that you get as a result is a
synthesis of Mughal and Hindu Islamic
and you
European classical and gothic traditions
and this eclectic architectural mix was
very often used in buildings that were
related to public institutions in some
way like post offices and hospitals
train stations etc and actually to a
large extent it was also a symbol of
Britain's rule over India trying to
establish its dominance and power with
these really flamboyant and grand
institutional buildings trying to
impress and sort of legitimize their
rule almost and it's interesting that
even in post independence or India a lot
of these buildings have been put on the
Heritage List and this architecture is
also inspired a lot of well architecture
actually created by Indians because in
those era sonic architecture featured a
lot of British Architects but yeah its
overall considering that whole history
the regardless of politics I love the
mix of different architectural styles
from all over the world that this style
combines together and I think it's a
really cool kind of architectural style
to build in planets who because as soon
as I actually saw the scenario during
Gamescom I realised that you could very
well put the pieces together to make in
those serious enok buildings so
featuring all of the typical elements
that it has like onion domes overhanging
eaves painted and gothic like arches and
many of these domed villians that Indian
architecture is very much known for it's
just this really cool bunch of elements
and I should probably actually talk
about the building which I'm building
right here this is going to be the
longest time lapse actually this is a
food court building and this was my
first kind of time that I messed around
with this style and it's definitely
going to be the largest most expensive
and most flamboyant building out of the
whole series I was just trying to
experiment as much as possible with the
different pieces to see how you can put
them together so a lot of the the art
the architectural elements that I just
talked about come back in this
the the certain type of arches that you
see the domed pavilions on top of the
building and just in general it's a mix
of different styles and even overall I
think the general composition of the
building is a bit European which also
kind of reflects the indo-saracenic
history being very much detailing from
Indian and Islamic architecture but at
the same time very much composition from
British architecture anyway that's all
for the food courts the next blueprint
that I wanted to work on is a staff
facility building where I put all of the
different stuff facilities that you need
to start a zoo in the game and this was
inspired by a bunch of stuff facility
buildings on the workshop already which
I figured is probably quite handy
because then all you need to do is plop
down this one blueprint and you don't
have to worry about putting a bunch of
different stuff facilities in the park
so it's kind of a good starting point
in general I try to make these
blueprints actually usable because a lot
of people rightfully pointed out after
the Japanese tea house build it is
pretty useless so I want to make sure
that at least these blueprints are
useable and could potentially be put in
place in a single Park if you're going
for an Indian style and I'm not sure if
these blueprints are actually going to
survive into the full game I am building
everything on the assumption that we're
going to lose all of these blueprints
eventually when the beta has ended but
if they do stay around and if frontier
does figure out how to make the
blueprints carry over into the full game
that would that would be absolutely
brilliant because then these blueprints
will actually be quite useful I think
now this building was just kind of
inspired by a bizarre layout so we have
two rows of buildings on both sides and
an open area in the middle of it where
all of the paths could connects and this
would also be an area where the guests
of the park won't actually be able to go
so I'm not entirely sure if it's a good
idea to make this as fancy as I'm making
it right now because it's essentially a
backstage building but I figured you
know it's still a good exercise
to get used to the pieces and see what
you can actually do with it so yeah I
decided to go a bit all out on theming
this building even though it wasn't
really necessary and hell it's even
stranger because it's very much an
inward lis focused building you know
these buildings are the nicest I think
when you're looking at them from the
inside from the the streets between the
two buildings and from the outside
there's actually a lot less detail and
interest so it's a bit curious in that
regard I guess if you really wanted to
you could actually take out some of the
staff buildings and instead put some
restaurants in it and make it some sort
of entrance area or main streets some
kind of Plaza where guests could have
their facilities but in my case I
figured this would be a good setup to
make a star facility building because a
lot of them on the workshop so far are
very functional they're really just
focused on being a starting point for
the game and not necessarily on being
the most beautiful buildings out there
so I thought it would be a cool
experiments to try and at least make
them look a bit nicer as well and yeah I
also just put two dome Vivien's on top
of either side of the buildings which if
my pronunciation is somewhat decent at
least they're called chat trees and
they're a very common element in
traditional Indian architecture so it's
something at least to give the building
some Flair but aside from that they're
very standard traditional and kind of
classical honestly galleries and also
this is my first time experimenting with
the letters in the game which are
absolutely amazing they make it so much
easier to make signs I guess it'll be a
bit unfortunate that all of the signs
are going to have pretty much exactly
the same fonts but I really love the
letters and just how flexible you are in
placing them down and the fact that we
even got a bunch of extra characters you
can even make hashtags and stuff like
that anyway this is what they look like
just some photos I'm adding a few
pictures after every time lapse just to
give you an idea of what these
blueprints look like but let's move on
to the next one which is going to be
the greenhouse now I really wanted to
try and build a greenhouse as soon as I
saw the glass pieces that are in the
game because they're really great and a
quite versatile as well there are a
bunch of different curved elements and
the shapes when it comes to these glass
pieces I don't think any of them are
off-grid though they are all pretty much
wall or roof pieces but even then
they're very flexible with all of the
different shapes that they have so
that's really nice and especially since
Rudy made his lemur dome I realized that
I really wanted to experiment a bit with
the glass pieces as well so here it goes
this will actually be a bit of an
interesting mix between traditional
architecture and very contemporary
architecture the kind of combination of
all brick buildings and a glass part on
top which is always a bit controversial
I mean in traditionalist circles and the
internet there is almost always so much
going around about buildings like the
Reichstag in Germany or the the Hearst
Tower in New York you know the drill
these old buildings which they just put
a bunch of glass on top of to add a new
use to it and personally I kind of like
it
sometimes it's terrible sometimes it's
amazing and I was at least trying my
best to make this building be more on
the amazing side even though it is quite
small and it's really just me trying to
mess around with the pieces I think I
was at least trying to reflect the
shapes of the more traditional side of
the building in the glass so hence why
you have this kind of vaulted arch shape
to the glass and I think and maybe this
is pushing it a bit but my intent my
intended sort of pattern for the glass
was also to kind of resemble a lotus
flower with this pointed arch in the
middle which is the tallest and then
these lower arches kind of edging to the
side I think it kind of works by
referring to the elements referring to
the shapes that are in the traditional
parts in the glass part of the building
at least it isn't to dissonance
and it's always a good opportunity also
to make use of different pieces in the
sets because in this building for
instance I was using some of the tower
pieces to make the front which I hadn't
really used so far because unfortunately
these pieces are not recoverable but
even then they do have a nice sensitive
texture that I wanted to try and play
around with so this building was really
my first foray into all of the sandstone
pieces in the Indian theme and see what
you can do with those and they're quite
versatile as you can see there are so
many different little elements like
different pillars and trims for roofs
and spires that really you can vary a
lot in terms of what you're building so
I'm really a big fan of the diversity in
pieces in these packs so far now the
inside of this is going to be a bit of a
mix I was originally thinking that this
would be a really cool building to house
a small atrium for birds or something
like that but obviously that's not in
the game
so my second idea was to make it an
exhibit building with some greenhouse
elements I really love greenhouses in
botanical gardens and such where you can
step into a tropical or desert biome and
this building is very similar to that
generally it was a way to put a bunch of
palm trees in the middle of this and
then mix it with some exhibits
I only fit for exhibits into this
building because they're really
expensive which I didn't really realize
before I built this but it makes sense
totally but it meant that I couldn't
really go all out on this building
unless I not run out of money which in
fact I did
at the end of construction of this one
so I have to stop adding stuff to it at
some point but yeah that's basically it
so this is what it looks like from the
outside with the glass arches and the
towers and I think it's a decent mix of
the two materials at least I'm pretty
happy with it
now moving into a much smaller blueprint
this is going to be a small store for
food which I figured was also quite
necessary so far all the blueprints have
been very large and fairly expensive so
I wanted to build something small that
you could actually just lop down next to
a road and turn into a snack corner or
something like that and for this one I'm
again bringing back the sandstone pieces
to use a few more sensitive pieces that
I haven't used before I'm actually using
a domed pavilion for the site there and
then putting some tower pieces on top of
that which I think works fairly well and
then there are a bunch of different
decorations and trims on top of the
walls this building will be much simpler
than some of the other ones it's really
just coming down to you know if you have
a very simple shape a very simple
building which is just a food store how
can you add detail to it what are the
scenery pieces like and it's especially
a good building for stuff like clutter
so you can see me browsing a lot through
the clutter section here and I have to
say it's absolutely amazing I think the
Indian theme is probably my favorite in
the game so far for all of the clutter
options alone lots of baskets and sex
and even fruits and all kinds of things
that you would need to build a
marketplace but these can really be used
quite well to add the scenery of areas I
put a little rickshaw under the roof as
well I don't know maybe in the plots of
this building it could be used as some
sort of delivery service but you know
given that I wanted to add a small roof
to this building to make it a little bit
less Square and boxy putting a rickshaw
underneath it would be quite realistic I
guess so
that's it for this building this is what
this blueprint looks like in the end and
with that said it's time to move on to
the final blueprints of this this whole
video which is going to be a toilets
building because I didn't have any
toilets so far and I've always forgotten
about toilets beard in my Park Tech
videos or planet coaster videos or
rollercoaster kin 3 videos or even
roller coaster [ __ ] videos I just always
forget about toilets and
in this case I'm gonna try to change my
ways and become a better person and not
forget about toilets anymore and my
first step is to build an Indian toilet
blueprints before I forget that actually
come to think of it my first blueprint
in this game was a toilet the the tudor
toilets but yeah anyway this is going to
be a very simple building as well not
much bigger than a toilet building would
realistically need to be but I'm
experimenting with a few different
pieces in this one mostly the limestone
pieces to see how they work together
with the other wall pieces I should say
I'm using a lot of painted walls here
because from my quote-unquote research
of google imaging a lot of Indian cities
in architecture I found that painted
walls seems to be quite a common thing
so I ended up using painted walls on all
of these blueprints in some way and on
this one I tried combining them with the
limestone pieces to see how that works
together and there's even some brick as
an extra detail to add some color into
this building
lest it not be completely white and very
monochrome so I think these textures
honestly work very well together and it
might just be because you know the game
is quite new and we haven't seen a lot
of pieces being used I think in planet
coaster for instance the fact that the
game is a few years old does make it a
bit more boring to see the same pieces
over and over again and everything here
is still fresh so that automatically
kind of makes things look more
interesting I think but still a lot of
these different textures from even the
different themes in the game work really
well together I think given the fact
that the limestone pieces come from the
classic theme the painted walls are a
generic thing I think and then the other
details are all from the Indian theme
but even so they all fit very well
together I think so I'm really happy
about that
although to actually make these
buildings look sufficiently Indian I'm
really focusing on the Indian theme when
it comes to the minor details like the
windows and arches and brackets and
things like that
I was actually considering for a while
to put some sort of dome or decoration
on top of the front of this building but
I've done that for every building in
this bank so
and I really wanted one building which
is a bit more subdued and simple
not to mention that domes are pretty
expensive you know not in the game but
realistically speaking so I needed to
calm it down a little bit on my dome
fixation so ended up not including one
in this build also this was my first
time messing around with the vines in
the game and they're absolutely amazing
there's such an improvement over the
planet coaster one and it's it's a nice
small touch to any building I think to
make it look a bit more lift in and a
bit more like an actual old building and
yeah that is basically it for this
blueprint I put some foliage around it
to make it look a bit more like it's
actually in an Indian context but that's
about it so yeah I'd like to thank you
guys for watching this video and
hopefully I'll see you in a planet to
franchise video sometime soon and if you
want to check out any of the blueprints
just a reminder that they'll be down in
the description there will be a link to
the workshop bye guys